[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Sonntag sportlich ein sehr
erfolgreicher Tag für Deutschland
macht gerade der Bundeskanzler
auf Tuchfühlung mit Südamerika Kanzler
Scholz macht sich in Argentinien für
mehr Handel und Zusammenarbeit stark
wenn die Software selber textet ein
neues Programm formuliert tadellos holt
sich dafür wissen aus dem Netz und sorgt
für Diskussionen
und
Sensationssieg in Indien in einem
dramatischen WM-Finale gewinnt das
deutsche hockey team gegen
Titelverteidiger Belgien
[Musik]
das Metall lithium ist unerlässlich für
Akkus in Handys Laptops oder auch
Elektroautos in Argentinien und Chile
Lagern riesige vorkommen davon das ist
ein Grund warum der Bundeskanzler nach
Südamerika gereist ist die
Bundesregierung will neue Allianzen
schmieden bzw alte vertiefen vor allem
bei Rohstoffen und Energie aber auch
beim Klimaschutz aus Buenos Aires
berichtet Klaus Brodbeck
12.000 Kilometer 14 Stunden Flug und ein
Kanzler der zu Beginn seiner
Südamerika-Reise vieles miteinander
verbinden möchte Beispiel Klimaschutz
argentinien will die Klimaziele von
Paris erreichen Deutschland will dabei
helfen da bieten sich Chancen
wenn es um den Ausbau von Windkraft geht
von
Solarenergie von Wasserkraft und
natürlich auch die Entwicklung von
grünen Wasserstoff wir sind sehr
interessiert diese Zusammenarbeit auch
weiter fortzusetzen eine
Wirtschaftsdelegation begleitet den
Kanzler die Regierungen vereinbaren
Start-ups beider Länder zu fördern auch
bei Rohstoffen wollen Berlin und Buenos
Aires enge zusammenarbeiten
es sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein
Kanzler auf handlungsreise das ist es
aber nicht Putins Krieg gegen die
Ukraine bestimmt auch hier die Gespräche
Südamerika leidet unter den Auswirkungen
die Preise explodieren Nahrungsmittel
werden knapp
Argentinien verurteilt in russischen
Überfall will die Ukraine aber auch
weiter nur politisch unterstützen
Argentinien und Lateinamerika denken
nicht daran Waffen zu schicken nicht die
Ukraine nicht in einen anderen Konflikt
noch einen Zweck hat die Reise den
politischen und wirtschaftlichen
Einfluss Chinas und Russlands
einzudämmen lange hat Europa die Region
vernachlässigt
in der Ukraine wartet das Militär
händeringend auf die zugesagten Waffen
aus Deutschland unter anderem den
Schützenpanzer Marder und den
Kampfpanzer Leopard 2
bereits im Einsatz ist der Flakpanzer
Gebhard das Flugabwehrsystem ihres tslm
sowie die Panzerhaubitze 2000 wie diese
Panzerhaubitze den ukrainischen Soldaten
hilft an dem besonders schwer umkämpften
Frontabschnitt bei bachmut zeigt Katrin
Eigendorf
wir sind unterwegs mit der ukrainischen
Armee an der Frontlinie von bachmut es
ist noch früh am Morgen die Soldaten
wollen uns eine deutsche Panzerhaubitze
im Einsatz zeigen
wie hat der Einsatz der hobbitse die
Situation verändert
sehr stark früher haben wir mit
sowjetischen zwei Spionen gearbeitet im
Vergleich zu dieser Technik ist diese
viel schneller manövriert besser die
Schüsse erfolgen viel schneller und sie
sind viel präziser
die Soldaten warnen uns es wird sehr
laut werden ihr Ziel sind russische
Artilleriestellungen die nur acht
Kilometer entfernt sind
dass die Haubitze von russischen
Militärs entdeckt wird ist eine der
großen Sorgen der Soldaten nach jedem
Einsatz wird sie in eine geschützte
Position gefahren
obwohl wir uns nicht so lange aufhalten
sollen dürfen wir noch einen Blick ins
Innere werfen Genia erklärt uns das ist
hier besonders gefährlich ist
weil wir hier in der Nähe von bachmut
sind wir verteidigen bachmut das ist der
heißeste Punkt hier
die Soldaten die hier im Einsatz sind
haben alle eine Ausbildung in
Deutschland bekommen und sie haben uns
erzählt dass sie sehr dankbar dafür sind
dass sie hier deutsche Technik haben
denn das würde einen großen Unterschied
in diesem Krieg machen als wir den
Stützpunkt verlassen ist in der Ferne
schon das Feuer russischer Artillerie zu
hören der Angriff auf die Stadt geht
weiter
die israelische Regierung hat neue
anti-terrorregeln beschlossen als
Reaktion auf die jüngsten Anschläge von
Palästinensern das Sicherheitskabinett
von Regierungschef Netanjahu legte fest
dass Angehörigen von Attentätern künftig
weitere Rechte entzogen werden können
und Israelis sollen leichter
Schusswaffen kaufen können ein weiterer
Punkt der Ausbau der Siedlungen in den
besetzten Gebieten
in Iran starben bei einem Erdbeben
mindestens drei Menschen mehr als 800
wurden verletzt das Leben der Stärke 5,9
ereignete sich im Nordwesten des Landes
nahe der Grenze zur Türkei auch dort
waren Erschütterungen zu spüren
zahlreiche Gebäude wurden beschädigt
oder stürzten ein in der Region kommt es
immer wieder zu Erdbeben weil dort
verschiedene Erdplatten aneinander
stoßen
es ist ein bisschen gruselig ein
Computerprogramm das Zulassungsprüfungen
für Ärzte besteht das auf Zuruf Gedichte
schreibt oder Aufsätze formuliert Chat
GPT nennt sich das Ganze künstliche
Intelligenz die vieles verändern könnte
Schüler haben das Programm schon als
schummelhilfe entdeckt die LINKE fordert
jetzt von der Bundesregierung die
Schulen damit nicht allein zu lassen wie
Studierende damit umgehen zeigt Sven
erster Kontakt mit einer künstlichen
Intelligenz einige Studierende dieser
Hamburger Privat-Uni sehen das
Online-Programm zur GPT zum ersten Mal
kann man auch noch Meinungen Fragen und
das System greift auf das nahezu gesamte
internetwissen zurück es schreibt Text
wie zum Thema Mode und Nachhaltigkeit
Aufsätze Hausaufgaben in
Sekundenschnelle es gibt auch seine
Meinung wieder etwa über soziale Medien
soziale Medien erleichtern auch die
Verbreitung von Nachrichten und
Informationen und ermöglichen es
Menschen ihre Meinung und Erfahrungen
mit einer breitern Öffentlichkeit zu
teilen für wissenschaftliche Arbeit ist
das natürlich erforderlich dass man
Quellen auch angegeben bekommt man kann
ja nicht sagen okay das kommt aus der
und der Quelle und ich denke mal nicht
dass das Quelle ist jemand angehen
sollte also in der Schule wenn man jetzt
zum Beispiel gerade für deutsche oder so
muss man ja keine Quellenangaben geben
wenn man was analysiert oder
zusammenfasst oder so und dann kann er
auch eigentlich nicht nachgewiesen
werden ob man sich das jetzt von dieser
künstlichen Intelligenz hat schreiben
lassen tatsächlich sind schon erste
Programme auf dem Markt die prüfen
können ob ein Text von Chat GPT erstellt
wurde das Ganze folgt ja immer einer
gewissen Struktur und im Muster wieder
Textaufbau beispielsweise ist das heißt
wenn ich jetzt eine Arbeit habe die
genau diesen Muster folgt dann kann ich
natürlich schon immer überlegen nach ist
schon sehr Standard 08 15 die
Studierenden in Hamburg können sich
trotzdem viele Einsatzmöglichkeiten
vorstellen Liedtexte schreiben etwa von
einem Liebespaar im Kornfeld ob das so
wohl auch ein Hit geworden wäre sie
fanden ein Bett im Kornfeld ein Ort
voller Erinnerungen sie wussten dass sie
füreinander bestimmt waren sie würden
sich immer lieben auf ewig
so hören unsere Filme auch selten auf
jetzt nach Indien
die Sensation ist perfekt Deutschland
ist Weltmeister
Belgien in einem Achterbahn mit stets am
Ende der regulären Spielzeit 3:3 dann
Penalty schießen Deutschland mit den
stärkeren Nerven und dem ersten WM Gold
seit 17 Jahren
am Ende ist Torwart georgeberg der Held
er wird gleich drei panaltis der Belgier
ab es folgt grenzenloser jubeln
Deutschland liegt mal wieder mit zwei
Toren zurück als Stürmer Niklas Wellen
kurz vor der Pause der wichtige
Anschluss gelingt als Kapitän Max
Krampus im letzten Viertel ähnlich
spektakulär trifft liegt Deutschland
plötzlich vorne aber Belgien kann konnte
und der Ausgleich knapp zwei Minuten vor
dem Ende Penalty schießen Danneberg hält
drei der sieben belgischen versuche die
Deutschen comebackkönige sind
Weltmeister zum dritten Mal das hätte
vor dem Turnier kaum jemand für möglich
gehalten
ein hoch verdienter fünfter Platz für
Deutschland bei der Handball WM durch
den Erfolg gegen Norwegen hinten
sicherte Torwart Andreas Wolf mit 18
Paraden den Sieg und vorne waren es mit
jeweils fünf Toren lucavics Hefner und
Johannes Golla erfolgreich hier der
Kapitän mit dem Treffer zum 28 zu 24
entstand
[Applaus]
Novak Djokovic hat die Australian Open
gewonnen drei Satz Sieg gegen Stephanus
tizipas erzieht mit 22 Siegen in der
Grand slam-liste mit Rafael Nadal gleich
ja zum Wintersport und zum Erfolg von
Skirennfahrerin Lena Dürr die 31-Jährige
Sieg dem tschechischen Spindlermühle vor
der
us-überfliegerin Micaela Schiffe ihr
erstes Slalom Weltcup Sieg in ihrer
Karriere
ja und auch heute gab es wieder
deutsches WM-Gold im Eiskanal in Oberhof
beim Rodeln und in St Moritz im Skeleton
und Bob die winterbergerin Laura Nolte
hat immonobob den ersten deutschen
WM-Titel gewonnen im selben Wettbewerb
fuhr die Thüringerin Lisa buckwitz auf
den dritten Platz
im Zweierbob konnten Johannes Lochner
und Angie bei Georg Fleischhauer den
Favoriten Francesco Friedrich stoppen
und erstmals den WM-Titel gewinnen zum
Abschluss des scannen WM haben sich
Susanne Kreher und Christopher den Titel
im Mixed Team Event gesichert und auch
bei der Heimweh im in Oberhof wurde das
deutsche rodelteam mit einer Bereiter
Max Langenhahn und den Doppelsitzer Toni
Eger Sascha Benecken zum WM Titel
[Applaus]
wie du schon sagtest anfangs ein richtig
toller Tag für sportdeutschland das
Wetter
sieht
wechselnd Graupelschauern dazu stärker
bis stürmischer Westwind an der See und
im Bergland schwere Sturmböen
Höchstwerte ein bis neun Grad und auch
in den nächsten Tagen bleibt es sehr
windig und wechselhaft im Bergland mit
Schnee Christian Sievers freut sich auf
Sie im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
das gesamte 19 uhr-team sagt danke und
tschüss und wünscht Ihnen einen guten
Start in die neue Woche hier übernimmt
jetzt Theo call mit Berlin direkt